retour au festival de cannes pour saluer
le réalisateur égyptien youssef chahine
qui a reçu hier soir le prix du 50e
anniversaire du festival pour l'ensemble
de son oeuvre
son tout dernier film le destin présenté
à cannes est l'occasion d'un plaidoyer
contre le fanatisme et toutes les
intolérances nicole candu l'endroit 50e
anniversaire est remis à youssef chahine
pour l'enfant mais trop mal
peu d'éléments
trouver une récompense qui fait
l'unanimité
ovation debout spontanée pour ce
réalisateur qui va à cannes à l'âge de
24 ans présentait le fils d'union
aujourd'hui à 72 ans il continue envers
et contre tout à faire un cinéma
égyptien indépendant dérangeant au delà
des censures donc donner la possibilité
même même hollande de travail temporaire
seulement que la d'emplois
ce film le destin est un plaidoyer
contre le fanatisme dans l'andalousie du
12e siècle le philosophe averroès voit
ses livres brûlés par des intégristes et
se bat pour que ces oeuvres franchissent
malgré tout des frontières et le temps
je vais pouvoir lui donner mes émotions
au vraiment avoir vécu la même
expérience très dur et comédie musicale
épopée exaltante dans laquelle des
femmes qu'on se met l'amour et la
tolérance de génération en génération
effectivement comme ça c'est pourquoi je
m'étonne que quelques jim vente est la
première l'olp ans
et elle te boil l'égyptienne je t aime
célébrer les soixante dix ans ces
actrices elle irradie à visage découvert
et assument leur destin comme youssef
chahine
soyez gentil mettez-vous à un coup du
port à ma place j'ai le coeur qui bat
j'ai des papillons dans l'estomac et
j'attends ça depuis 47 ans